how do you maintain Focus for so many
hours of classical chess like like
um you know what like minute to minute
second to Second how are you able to
maintain focus is there tricks to that
how difficult is that I think it really
depends on the type of the game that
you're playing I think if it's a game
that's very very calm and very slow or
not a lot happens at the start it's a
it's a lot easier because because you're
not having to be super focused like your
mind can drift and whatnot and the
critical moment you have to sort of Zone
in
um so those are the easiest ones I think
generally when when games are very
complicated from the start uh what
you're doing is you're you're just
you're you're trying to not let your
mind wander at all because when games
are complicated like that one of the
things that I've never been very good at
is my mind does wander and you're always
like I'm always worrying about the next
move it's like is this a blunder what's
what's going on like what am I gonna do
um so you're trying I think very much to
block out the noise I think that's
actually the hardest thing is is also
because like I can say this when I
played Magnus before there have been
times when I've gotten winning positions
against him and in that moment when I
have the winning position very often
times my mind wanders like okay you're
about to win this game you're like okay
what happens after the game you win this
game gain the rating points all these
different things but you haven't
actually won the game yet and I think
for a lot of players that's the hardest
thing is when you get a winning position
your mind does drift it drifts to like
what the what happens after after you've
won the game or what the outcome is so
yeah drifting into the future and you
should stay in the moment you really
should yeah like hold on and also
what is it uh yeah probably getting
excited about the win what what is that
what is it about that that makes you
worse at playing
so interesting like getting uh well I
think it's you you get it's like a nerve
it's nervous but it's like you're you're
too excited I think you just you it's
like you're waiting for a time you
expect it to end and then and then your
opponent keeps keeps defending and and
you can make mistakes what about the
flip side of that where you start
getting frustrated like how do you try
to recover from that kind of thing it's
very difficult I I think for myself I
just try I try to basically focus on it
every single move I just try and again
you try to block out the noise no matter
which direction it's going in so I try
as best I can I mean sometimes I'm very
poor at it like I just don't do a good
job uh blocking out the noise at all but
I think generally I try to think okay
just make this next move make your
opponent have to find the best moves and
just just keep the game going no matter
what just keep it going by the way
what's a long day of classical chess
what's that look like this it's pretty
brutal I mean it would be something like
okay so the game starts at two o'clock
so you've done all this other stuff the
game probably goes from like two to
seven for example or maybe two to eight
five six hours probably eat uh you eat
dinner for an hour or so maybe clear
like I'll go clear my head for 30
minutes and then immediately it's right
back to studying for a couple of hours
are you reviewing previous games are you
already uh generally you're just moving
on to the next game that's what you're
not and trying to no matter what
happened put that behind you yeah win or
lose or draw
okay so that's that's also why there's
another question a lot of people wonder
which is why don't I play more of these
classical tournaments and
sort of it gets back to the you know the
literally don't care Source stuff but
when I'm going to play in tournaments I
want to be able to give it my best shot
and if I don't feel that I can I'm not
going to play which is why like I play
here and there but I do balance my
schedule very carefully because I'm not
just going to go and play tournament
simply because if I don't feel that I
can put in the work uh it's not it's not
it's not the right thing to do also
because I'm taking away a spot from
somebody else who probably will be
putting in the work who will want to
compete in that event and so when I look
at the candidates or a lot of people say
well why why is he playing there like
okay qualified but he's not going to
take it seriously
um but I did give it everything I had in
that tournament
um and I always will as much as I can if
I can't do that then I'm just not going
to play